do you think if you look at history of
progress
don't you think to achieve the quote
impossible you have to believe that it's
possible
absolutely yeah like his his his his
two great runs
great unbelievable
1903
first human
um power human uh
you know heavier than their flight yeah
1969 we land on the moon that's 66 years
i'm 66 years old in my lifetime that
span of my lifetime
barely get you know flying i don't know
what it was 50 feet or the length of the
first flight or something to landing on
the moon
unbelievable
fantastic but that requires by the way
one of the wright brothers
both of them but one of them didn't
believe it's even possible like a year
before
right so
like not just possible soon but like
yeah
so so so you know how important is it to
believe and be optimistic is what i
guess oh yeah it is important it's when
it goes crazy when when when
i you know you said what was the word
you used for my bad harshness harshness
yes
i just get so frustrated yes when when
people make these leaps
and tell me that i'm that i don't
understand right i
you know yeah
there's
just from
irobot which i was co-founder of yeah i
don't know the exact numbers now because
i haven't it's ten years since i stepped
off the board but i believe it's well
over 30 million
robots cleaning houses from that one
company and now there's lots of other
companies yesterday
was that a crazy idea that we had to
believe
in 2002 when we released it
yeah that was we we had we had to you
know
believe that it could be done let me ask
you about this so irobot one of the
greatest robotics companies ever
in terms of manufacturing
creating a robot that actually works in
the real world probably the greatest
robotics company ever
you were the co-founder of it
um
if if the
rodney
brooks of today talked to the rodney
back then
what would you tell him because i have a
sense that
would you pet him on the back and say
what you're doing is going to fail
but go at it anyway
that's what i'm referring to is with the
harshness you've accomplished
an incredible thing there one of several
things we'll talk about
what like that's what i'm trying to get
at that line
no it's it's when
my harshness is reserved for people who
are not doing it
who claim it's just well this shows that
it's just going to happen but here
here's the thing
this shows but you have that harshness
for elon too
and no no it's a different harshness no
it's it's a
different um
argument with yuan you know i
i think spacex is an amazing company on
the other hand
you know i in one of my blog posts i
said what's easy and what's hard i said
space x
vertical landing rockets it had been
done before
grid fins have been done since the 60s
every soyuz has them
reusable space um dcx reused those
rockets that landed vertically um
there was a whole insurance industry in
place for
rocket launches so all sorts of
infrastructure
that
was doable it took a great entrepreneur
a great personal
expense he almost drove himself you know
bankrupt doing it
a great belief to do it
whereas hyperloop
uh there's a whole bunch more stuff
that's never been thought about never
been demonstrated so my estimation is
hyperloop is a long lot long a lot
further off but and if i've got a
criticism of of of elon it's that he
doesn't make distinctions
between
when the technology's
coming along and ready and then he'll go
off and and mouth off about other things
which then people go and compete about
and try and do
and
so
this is where i uh
i i understand what you're saying i tend
to draw a different distinction
i
i have
a similar kind of harshness towards
people who are not telling the truth
who are
basically fabricating stuff to make
money or to well he believes what he
says like this thing to me that's a very
important difference yeah i'm not
because i think uh in order to fly in
order to get to the moon you have to
believe um even when uh most people tell
you you're wrong and most likely you're
wrong but sometimes you're right i mean
that's the same thing i have with tesla
autopilot i think that's an interesting
one i was especially when i was you know
um at mit and just the entire human
factors in the robotics community were
very negative towards elon it was very
interesting for me to observe colleagues
at mit
i wasn't sure what to make of that that
was very upsetting to me
because i understood without where
that's coming from
and i agreed with them and i kind of
almost felt the same thing in the
beginning until i kind of opened my eyes
and and
realize there's a lot of interesting
ideas here there might be over hype you
know
if if you focus yourself on the idea
that um
you shouldn't call a system full
self-driving
when it's obviously not
autonomous fully autonomous
you're going to miss the magic oh
yeah you are going to miss the magic but
at the same time there are people who
buy it
literally pay money for it yeah and take
those words as given so it's that's uh
but i haven't so
that i
take words as given as one thing i
haven't actually seen people that use
autopilot that believe that the behavior
is really important like the actual
action so like this is like to push back
on the very thing that you're frustrated
about which is like journalists in
general people
uh
buying all the hype and going on
in the same way i think there's a lot of
hype about
the the negatives of this too that
people are buying without using people
used the way this is what this was this
opened my eyes actually
the way people use the product is very
different than the way
they talk about it this is true with
robotics with everything everybody has
dreams of how a particular product might
be used or so on this and then when it
meets reality there's a lot of fear of
robotics for example that robots are
somehow dangerous and all those kinds of
things but when you actually have robots
in your life whether it's in the factory
or in the home making your life better
that's going to be
that's way different your perceptions of
it are going to be way different and so
my
just tension was was like here's an
innovator
um
uh like
uh uh
uh what is it sorry super cruise from
cadillac was super interesting too
that's a really interesting system
there's an if we should like be excited
by those innovations okay so can i tell
you something that's really annoyed me
recently
it's really annoyed me that
the press and friends of mine on
facebook are going these billionaires
and their space games you know why are
they doing that yeah that's very
frustrating really pisses me off i must
say i i applaud that yeah i applaud it
it's the taking
and not necessarily the people who are
doing the things but
you know like that i keep having to push
back against
on realistic expectations when
these things can become real yeah i
this was interesting ana because there's
been a particular focus for me is
autonomous driving
elon's prediction of when certain
milestones would be hit uh
there's several things to be said there
that i always i thought about because
whenever you said them it was obvious
that's not going to me as a person that
kind of
not inside
the system it was obvious it's unlikely
to hit those
uh there's two comments i want to make
one
he legitimately believes it
and two much more importantly
i think
that
having ambitious deadlines drives people
to do the best work of their life even
when the odds of those deadlines are
very um
to a point and i'm not sure i'm not
talking about anyone yeah i'm just
saying so there's a line there right you
have to have a line because
you over extend and it's
it's demoralizing yeah
[Music]
but i will say that there's an
additional thing here
that those words
also um
drive the stock market
yeah and you know we have because of the
way that rich people in the past have
manipulated
the rubes
through investment we have um um we have
developed laws about what you know what
you're allowed to say and yeah i promise
and you know there's an area here which
is
i i i tend to be
maybe i'm naive but i i tend to believe
uh that uh like engineers innovators
people like that they're not
they're my they don't think like that
like manipulating the price at the stock
price but
it's possible that i'm uh i'm certain
it's possible that i'm wrong
i it's a very cynical view of the world
because i don't i think most people that
run companies and build
like especially original
founders they um yeah i'm not saying
that's the intent i'm saying it's a
eventually it's kind of you uh yeah
you you fall into that kind of a
behavior pattern i don't know i i tend
to
i wasn't saying i wasn't saying it's
falling into that intent it's just a
you also have to protect investors in
this in this market yeah
you